my name is Walter benezia for months I
was trapped in the evil Dynel ROVs dial
dimension a place where I was duplicated
dozens of times eventually I managed to
escape but now die rob is sending his
army to take me back with the help of my
friends he fight them off and hoped to
ultimately take down mr. rage dinosaur
the more we countdown the weaker he gets
this is top-5
[Music]
what I said we brought you here today
because we're your friends and we're
concerned about your well-being thanks
but my birthday's not till May the dummy
dummy
oh you mean Walter to point out Walter
using language like that is hurtful and
this is a safe space
now Ayana why do you feel like you need
Walter here Wow
rude Walter is sitting right there
this is Walter 2.0 I just thought it'd
be fun to bring them back since we're
doing another comic themed episode thank
God I'm sorry what was that Walter 2.0
yep that was about right here are the
top 5 best DC movies number 5 Batman
Begins I talked about how much this film
means to me and my top 5 best
Christopher Nolan movies video and I
have no problem seeing its praises again
Bruce Wayne travels the world searching
for the means to fight injustice
eventually Henri Ducard and the League
of Shadows find him and teach him their
ways Bruce relents when he sees that the
league's extreme teachings don't match
up with his own moral code when the
still determined orphan billionaire
returns to Gotham things start falling
into place for the birth of the Batman
this movie obviously paved the way for
its massively successful sequel but
Batman Begins deserves a lot of credit
for turning things around for this
character and in a larger sense comic
book films in general it set a tone that
many movies and TV shows tried to match
for years to come Gotham reimagined as
an almost realistic city with very
distinct areas like the Narrows created
a relatable world for our hero and his
catalog of supporting characters to
inhabit the atmosphere established here
is a big reason why it fits into the top
bot after destroying the franchise in 97
s Batman and Robin Batman Begins needed
to be a success while taking Batman to a
much different place from the last time
we saw him on the big screen it
accomplished that and much more while I
love Michael Keaton Christian Bale is
still my favorite live-action Batman
actor I'm not saying he's perfect but I
was ecstatic to see more layers to this
character than had ever been explored in
any big-screen film before this with
maybe the exception of mask of the
phantasm Bale plays up Bruce's facade as
a reckless playboy and nails Batman the
voice is fine here it gets way more
ridiculous in the next film he also
shows us the vulnerable man beneath it
all in some fantastic scenes with
Michael Caine's Alfred and Katie Holmes
Rachel dogs number four Batman Returns
oh look Batman Returns to our countdown
energy tycoon max Shreck assists Gotham
outlier Oswald Cobblepot to gain
political power and drag Batman's good
name through the sewers
unfortunately Shrek also had a hand in
his Secretary's downfall and she's got a
bone to pick with her employer now
Batman must face these new foes while
keeping his name clean and true identity
a secret where others have struggled to
do justice to classic comic lawbreakers
this film managed to pull off two solid
villain origins from the grotesque
drooling to his little grunts and groans
Danny DeVito's performance is startling
in this film can be such a
two-dimensional experience but thanks to
the brilliant work is a production
design I swear you can almost smell the
actual penguins swimming alongside his
rubber ducky paddleboat michelle
pfeiffer captured Selina Kyle's duality
with aplomb they blended her dark side
really well with quippy punchlines and
made us empathize with her dilemma
between revenge and happiness sure
there's occasionally cheesy dialogue but
this film hits in all the right places
amazing soundtrack top-notch costumes
incredible casting and some classic bad
guy action even a lot of the practical
effects have held up surprisingly well
I'm also a sucker for a well-timed
one-liner
I haven't been fed all day eat more
high-fiber number three Wonder Woman
Wonder Woman was arguably the best part
of Batman V Superman so expectations
were high for her solo film debut and
honestly we loved it the movie opens
onthe mascara the island home of the
Amazons Princess Diana wants to be a
warrior to fight for peace and justice
spies Steve Trevor accidentally stumbles
onto the island he tells them of the
Great War and Diana is compelled to go
with him to help free man from the grip
of Ares the God of War there are so many
elements that came together to make this
movie great even though it was
structured as a typical origin story and
fish-out-of-water story it still felt
fresh the movie gave us a couple of
unforgettable scenes that are now iconic
superhero movie moments I still cannot
watch this scene without being moved to
tears
[Music]
gal gadot does a wonderful job of
playing the character she is strong yet
gentle understanding yet stubborn
knowing yet still filled with wonder at
the world of men her chemistry with
Chris Pine is great
they are coy and flirty and unforgiving
in their differences and beliefs their
relationship felt so genuine be careful
in the world of men Diana they do not
deserve you
truly we don't deserve her but I am sure
glad we got this movie number two
Superman the movie it says a lot that a
film from the 70s is still the
undisputed champion of Superman movies
the origin of the Man of Steel is told
in this epic motion picture from
director Richard Donner it covers
everything from the explosion of Krypton
to Cal's time in Smallville as Clark
Kent all the way to his debut as
Superman in Metropolis and battles with
Lex Luthor this is still the definitive
version of this character I think as
time has gone on it's apparent that we
may never get a better Superman than
Christopher Reeve he's the first thing
that comes to my mind when I think of
Superman and it's like that for people
older than me and younger than me he's
transcended generations to be known as
the one true man of tomorrow his
fantastic dual performance as the
confident robust defender from another
planet and the goofy bumbling reporter
cannot be understated he made us believe
there were two different characters more
importantly he made us believe a man
could fly none of that is on display
more than in his first go-around as
Superman the set designs and general
look of Krypton have become iconic from
the crystals Superman uses to speak to
his long deceased father to the fortress
of solitude itself this film contributed
much more to the Superman mythos than
just the best interpretation of a
live-action Man of Steel there's an
intangible magic to this movie that
makes any of its flaws instantly
forgivable it's something that just
cannot be recreated nowadays for
whatever reason don't get me wrong I
wish
find the balance to tell a faithful
Superman story with this type of tone
modernized but it just may not be
possible Bryan Singer tried and failed
with Superman Returns and the DCE use
version has divided audiences at best
maybe that's what makes this movie so
special and why it's so important its
legacy needs to live on for as long as
we have this film we need not look up in
the sky because with just a few notes of
John Williams masterful score or a
playful wink from Reeves Clark Kent the
true spirit of Superman will always be
close by
[Music]
and the number one best bc movie is the
dark knight yeah that's right another
Batman since Batman has been on the
streets of Gotham crime has gone down
sharply as police lieutenant Jim Gordon
and District Attorney Harvey Dent
continue to round up the bigger crime
bosses a new class of criminals starts
to gain traction The Joker's something
Batman has never dealt with before this
agent of chaos turns the city's plans
for salvation on their head and aims to
show everyone the only sensible way to
live in this world is without rules
knowing he couldn't touch what Jack
Nicholson had previously accomplished
Heath Ledger's original casting
announcement was not widely accepted but
what we were left with was the pinnacle
of performances for this darker nolan
world they sensibly changed the Joker's
classic clown caricature to this darker
imperfection that sweated over his
scarred lips and lines to remind us the
Joker is not a monster but a man of
flesh and blood still capable of so many
Horrors yet another costume that was the
icing on the characters cake hello
nerves Ledger's performance is well
remembered from the unique choice of
mannerisms like darting his tongue to
that laughs but the writing also
fostered a sense of mystery with the
ever-changing explanation of his past he
was everything you could want from a
villain that chills you to your core a
joker that truly was chaos for chaos
sake I need to give a shout out to how
amazing Aaron Eckhart was as Harvey Dent
in this movie because Ledger was so
extraordinary I think Eckhart was very
underappreciated his fall from White
Knight that total darkness is handled
very well when I first saw this film I
thought the climax was a tad rushed
since it seemed tailor-made as a set up
for the third film with two-face as the
main villain we didn't get that but if
we did I think this version of the
character would have perhaps received
the recognition he so deserved this week
on my personal channel it's the best of
DC versus the best of marble that's
right
Logan versus The Dark Knight all
so my review of the recently released
three-hour cut of Superman the movie
will go up later this week so check it
all out for more comic book movie
content we want to hear what you guys
think what's your favorite DC movie what
you want to see is cover next on the
show leave us a comment and let us know
you can like my Facebook page or follow
along on Twitter to keep in touch you
can follow me on Twitter Instagram or
Twitter I stream on Wednesday nights and
you can find me on Facebook Twitter or
Instagram we'll see you next week at a
brand new episode of top 5
[Music]
[Applause]
you
enjoy the good times or they last you
confounded counters soon you'll be too
terrified to even look in a mirror
[Laughter]
you